[Musica]
salve parliamo di pregiudizi uno dei
pregiudizi che mi infastidisce di più
questa cosa di pensare che le persone
anziane normalmente siano di pessimo
umore sempre sappiamo questo cattivo un
carattere e questa sera mi piacerebbe
cercare di sfatare questo mio
pregiudizio perché mi vedete sono
giovanissima ma non avete idea di che
pessimo carattere coppia ed è un
carattere bruto che mi fa stare sempre a
braccia conserte adesso vedete
un'eccezione
io ho questo brutto carattere più o meno
da che mi ricordi da sempre da quando ho
iniziato ad andare a scuola
all'asilo dalle suore e le suore mi
offrivano le caramelle al liquore
come si fa a dare delle caramelle al
contro a una bambina di tre anni ma
questa è una faccenda che riguarda le
suore
il punto è che il mio pessimo carattere
è rimasto invariato nonostante io poi mi
si è abituata ad apprezzare il liquore e
questa è un po la dimostrazione secondo
me di una mia teoria secondo cui nell
alcol nella scolarizzazione cooperino a
rendere una persona di buon carattere e
di buon umore
quindi non bisogna eccedere nei con una
né con l'altra ecco però nel momento in
cui una cella sto pessimo carattere
tanto vale farci qualcosa e allora io
con questo carattere di merda ho fatto
un mestiere io di lavoro scrivo libri
testi comici
pensate un po però sono dei testi che io
definisco tristo comici perché mi piace
provocare quel tipo di risata che in uno
quando legge una mia cosa
che vita di merda
immaginatevi con questo pessimo
carattere che grandi ispirazioni io
trovi nella società di oggi
no io vivo in un paese con 12 abitanti
più o meno al massimo 15 eppure nelle
piante nei fiori nelle città negli
animali e nelle persone soprattutto mi
piace trovare questo lato un po di merda
di ognuno di noi e anche delle delle
cose delle situazioni degli eventi l'ho
fatto anche prima di venire qui al ted
quando ho ricevuto l'invito io ho
agganciato la cornetta o ancora la
cornetta nel mio paese e ho detto ok
cosa c'è sotto
perché questa è una cosa troppo [ __ ]
internazionale giovane allegra
intelligente
devo trovare il marcio devo trovare il
complotto
e allora mi sono messo al di come un
demonio a cercare i 100 buoni motivi per
non venire al ted non solo per non
venire al tema anche per richiamare e
dire guardate non vengo per questo
questo no come funziona l'organizzazione
sono felicissima di sapere che li ho
portati qui stasera ma col poco tempo
che ho per fortuna in questo periodo vi
comunico che ne ho trovati per ora solo
due abbastanza importanti però il primo
buon motivo per non venire al ted è che
all the degli speaker vengono gratis
e il mio papà e ligure
quando noi liguri riceviamo un invito ci
mettiamo tutta la buona volontà no e
accettiamo l'invito sorridendo con
l'entusiasmo ma dentro di noi
e i nostri organi interni di liguri si
rattrappisce rinsecchiscono city ed è
così però nonostante questo sono qui ho
lasciato il carrellino di là il secondo
buon motivo per non venire al ted
per me era questo pregiudizio io sono
piena di pregiudizi pregiudizi sono
frutto di una grande ignoranza e io
ignoravo
in realtà come funzionasse per bene il
ted e pensavo che fosse una roba di
queste da da coach noda spilletta vuoi
dimagrire chiedimi come la forza ragazzi
ce la possiamo fare da tutorial su come
sviluppare le potenzialità e la propria
creatività ed adesso vi aiuto io doppio
che ansia perché non posso rimanere con
la mia pessima normalità non voglio
potenziare niente
al massimo però non penso che si scusa
allora dunque questi erano i motivi no
io questa cosa della motivazione e
allora ho deciso di venire al tel
per coerenza perché non potevo fare
altrimenti io sono una grande
motivatrice sono una motivatrice di me
stessa forse la migliore in circolazione
io mi motivo da sempre da quando mi
sveglio la mamma emotivo anche quando
non c'è motivo di motivarsi mi motivo
perché se non lo faccio
o la vita o il mio pessimo carattere di
merda di cui vi ho appena parlato mi
disintegrano è banale e fastidioso
ammetterlo ma l'unica persona che
realmente coopera per il nostro successo
è il nostro futuro è la persona con cui
conviviamo da sempre noi stessi e questa
è la brutta notizia di questa sera è un
po la faccenda della tifoseria no
immaginatevi se tutta l'energia e
l'entusiasmo che utilizziamo per tifare
la nostra squadra di calcio noi la
traslaval su di noi sembreremo dei
[ __ ] probabilmente però immaginatevi
stamparci una una sciarpetta no con il
nome anziché della nostra squadra da
lazio della juve con il nostro nome
alice marco matteo pensate che andare in
giro con questi cori da stadio che
dicono il nostro nome
arianna aria sembreremo senz'altro dei
dissociati
ma io credo che la nostra vita
migliorerebbe nel momento in cui
prendessimo in considerazione la
bellezza delle cose che siamo e che
abbiamo a disposizione e soprattutto
delle scelte che possiamo fare senza che
altri ne facciano per noi
qualche esempio rudimentale da ragazza
avrei tanto voluto iscrivermi al liceo
artistico ma la mia famiglia
considero meglio per iscrivermi al liceo
classico perché dicevano che mi avrebbe
offerto un futuro migliore ma io non
volevo un futuro migliore io come voi il
mio è un futuro se è possibile ancora le
vacanze per gli adolescenti sono
fondamentali
io da ragazzo volevo tanto andare a
ibiza con le amiche i miei probabilmente
percependo questa questo ideale che
avevo alla fine mi obbligarono ad andare
ai fino a vent'anni in camper con loro a
ferruzzano a locri in questi luoghi
felici in provincia di reggio calabria
belli per carità però a letto alle 20 30
a 20 anni in camper con i propri
genitori poi vedete perché è un pessimo
carattere avrei sempre voluto fare la
scrittrice comica e prima di poterlo
fare dio sa quale miracolo sia avvenuta
io ho dovuto attraversare delle
professioni poco felici che molti di noi
avranno senz'altro passato ho fatto la
commessa per la grande distribuzione
dove sei
meno di una più o fatto la cameriera
portando 7 pizze contemporaneamente con
il liquido della mozzarella
incandescente che ticona qui al centro
del gomito di un resting ridare quanto o
di la vita invece devi dire da
margherita
tutto questo è avvenuto in maniera
perfetta guardate puntuale precisa
pessima umiliante mortificante fino a
quando io sono stata lì a mettermi con
le mani così ea lasciar cadere le
briciole che gli altri che sceglievano
per me mi consegnavano ripetendomi
questo mantra con cui io credo che
nasciamo ormai le nuove generazioni di
sicuro no un mantra che ci ripetiamo
guarda come andrà di merda guarda come
andrà deserta è visto è andata una meta
te l'avevo detto
questo accade perché appunto concediamo
agli altri il privilegio di scegliere
per noi e per il discorso che abbiamo
fatto prima non è consigliabile a mio
avviso abbiamo degli strumenti e gli
strumenti me l'immagino come un cavallo
da corsa magari no perché qualcuno non
sempre al cavallo da corsa a volte
qualcuno tipo me ha un somaro ubriaco a
disposizione
insomma poca roba ecco ma se prendiamo
la testa di questo somaro ubriaco li
mettiamo occhi contro chi ci mettiamo
gli edili senti bello siamo qui io non
ho mai cavalcato tu sei ubriaco lercio
col caschetto di velluto nero sembra un
vigile inglese o un [ __ ] o le due
cose contemporaneamente
ma tanto vale divertirci divertiamoci
e questa è la parola chiave che vorrei
lasciarvi quando non ci sono più
il divertimento è inteso come stile di
vita
sì ma anche come significato etimologico
divertimento diverso di sentire bello
bello sarebbe no la leggerezza nella
maggior parte dei casi è considerata da
noi come un metodo di vita e o di
approccio s
completamente diverso
dalla maturità al saper vivere per
questo mi piace tantissimo quando
qualcuno mi dice quello quello lascialo
stare quello c'è la testa sulle nuvole
beato lui beato lui perché insomma la
testa sulle nuvole ti consente di
camminare un pochino più alto rispetto
alle schifezze che abbiamo oggi in
questa nostra epoca di vedere un po come
le aquile no e soprattutto di fare delle
scelte che ci corrispondono anche quando
sono bizzarre il suv la settimana bianca
la famiglia perfetta
sono tutte cose meravigliose se
corrispondono a quello che noi
desideriamo veramente altrimenti
risultano prima o poi indigeste come una
caramella liquore e allora mi piacciono
le persone che tengono presente anche il
suv ma provano a cavalcare sto cavallo
abbiamo detto un somaro ubriaco e lo
cavalcano così per il gusto di
divertirsi con un obiettivo unico che è
l'imprevisto il fuori programma
considerandolo non come una tragedia una
disgrazia ma come un'opportunità non
potrebbe essere altrimenti
un'opportunità e l'opportunità ce la
offre la vita con delle cose che magari
sembrano inspiegabili uno sfratto un
licenziamento una separazione un figlio
inatteso possono essere delle
opportunità ma ce la offrono anche le
persone che ci vogliono bene ultimamente
sarà che sto invecchiando sono diventata
una persona molle e con l'affettività
estremamente precaria dopo i miei
spettacoli mi viene questo senso di
enorme gratitudine nei confronti dei
miei genitori che mi hanno cresciuta con
queste frasi
quando ti trovi un lavoro
quando metti la testa a posto 96
ridicola queste le frasi per me non so
in che modo ma sono state il punto di
partenza di questo famoso dissenso del
divertimento di capovolgere la realtà
preconfezionata che mi veniva offerta
come unica possibile è un atteggiamento
che magari possiamo valutare perché non
è detto che un form compilato da qualcun
altro sia quello che noi desideriamo
magari la nostra felicità è ben altra
magari la nostra felicità sta in scelte
poco borghesi poco attinenti alla vita
per bene perché peggio della vita per
bene c'è solo una caramella liquore
offerta da una suora
e allora tanto vale divertirsi no visto
che comunque la vita fa un po come gli
pare sia che tu sia ingegnere ed i
programmi la vita al millimetro
sia che tu sia uno degli alcolisti
anonimi e la vita te la programmi giorno
per giorno aspettando quello che arriva
cogliendo il fuori programma la vita fa
come gli pare
e allora tanto vale godere del fuori
programma perché tutte le cose più belle
che ci sono sempre successe le persone
più belle più [ __ ] che incontriamo sono
frutto di un fuori programma e allora
accogliamo il fuori programma come una
cosa bella questo mi piacerebbe
insomma questa cosa qua perché magari la
nostra felicità non è la settimana
bianca o il posto fisso ma sono i
capelli blu il fidanzato punk che lo
porti al cinema gli altri non vedono il
film perché era cristo
ho un figlio chitarrista in un gruppo
hardcore o il nostro compagno delle
medie che amavamo tanto che si è
trasferito in kenya che pensavamo di
sposare perché no perché non palafitta
in costa rica invece che in un attico a
milano l'importante è accogliere tutto
come un'opportunità ma se vedete una
suora che vi offre una caramella liquore
sapete che una comportarvi siamo
d'accordo
grazie
[Applauso]